[Musique]
près de 3000 manifestants réunis cet
après midi à paris en soutien au peuple
palestinien en face à eux quatre mille
deux cents policiers et gendarmes
mobilisés canons à eau et gaz
lacrymogènes pour tenter de disperser
les protestataires
la manifestation parisienne a été
interdite par la préfecture de police de
la capitale mais les organisateurs ont
décidé de maintenir leur appel au
rassemblement
quarante-quatre personnes ont été
interpellées un gendarme a été blessé
[Musique]
pour proche orient le dernier bilan des
autorités palestiniennes fait état de
son 39 morts et 1000 blessés dans les
bombardements israéliens
ce samedi c'est l'immeuble qui abrite
les locaux d'al jazeera et l' agence de
presse américaine associated press qui a
été la cible d'une frappe de tsahal dans
la bande de gaza affrontements
meurtriers également en cisjordanie
nouveau front de ce conflit qui
s'envenime depuis lundi plus de 2300
roquettes ont été lancées par des
groupes armés palestiniens sur le
territoire israélien
furent neuf personnes et non plus de 500
francs
il
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france 22 mille
manifestants en france dont 2500 à 3500
à paris selon le ministère de
l'intérieur alors que la situation
s'embrase au proche orient
une trentaine d'associations pro
palestiniennes avaient appelé à
manifester dans la capitale en soutien
aux palestiniens manifestation interdite
hier par la préfecture de police de
paris sur demande du ministre de
l'intérieur gérald darmanin interdiction
confirmée par le tribunal administratif
de paris saisi par les organisateurs qui
ont malgré tout décidé de maintenir
l'appel au rassemblement des
affrontements ont éclaté entre
protestataires et forces de l'ordre
compte rendu de cette mobilisation
parisienne avec thomas bonnin fin de
manifestation après une journée tendue
des tensions qui auront commencé en
début d'après-midi lorsque des
manifestants ont tenté de se retrouver
au niveau du métro barbès ils en ont été
empêchés par l'important dispositif de
sécurité qui avait été mise en place
parce que cette manifestation vous le
savez avait été interdite par la
préfecture de police de paris au départ
donc quelques petits groupes de
manifestants de 10 voire 20 personnes
qui ont tenté de se retrouver cela a été
très compliqué puisqu'il y avait donc
une forte présence des forces de l'ordre
et puis à un moment un cortège s'est
formé d'environ 400 500 personnes et
parmi ce cortège quelques individus
violents qui ont lancé des projectiles
en direction des forces de l'ordre à
face à face très tendu qui s'est
poursuivie pendant une bonne partie de
l'après midi les tirs de gaz
lacrymogènes de canons à eau mais
également des tirs de l bd par les
forces de l'ordre en direction des
manifestants qui ont finalement été
dispersés en fin de journée beaucoup
avaient quand même décidé de venir
malgré l'interdiction pourra faire
entendre leurs revendications
montrer leur soutien avec le peuple
palestinien également exprimé à emmanuel
macron que sa position sur le dossier
israélo-palestinien ne leur convient pas
je vous propose d'écouter quelques-uns
des témoignages que nous avons
recueillis
on est avec le peuple palestinien on est
contre les agissements qui sont en train
de se passer actuellement nous on n'est
pas là pour casser on n'est pas là pour
abîmer des choses on est là pour rien
faire on veut marcher de manière
pacifique
exprimez vraiment le enfin ce qu'on
ressent et on trouve que c'est pas
normal de réprimer une manifestation de
la sorte on est là on se fait attaquer
par les forces de l'ordre
c'est ce qui se passe en palestine est
une mascarade le ce qui se passe on ne
peut pas faire un état sur les terres
des autres on nous les américains
protègent quelque chose qu'on ne peut
pas le protéger les français protègent
quelque chose on peut pas le protéger
il ya cinq cent mille juifs français qui
sont installés illégalement palestine
il faut leur pays c'est ici c'est en
france est pas là bas ils sont plus en
sécurité en france qu'en palestine
journée marquait donc par des violences
plusieurs dizaines d'interpellations un
gendarme a également été blessés pendant
cette journée de manifestations et
plusieurs autres manifestations
autorisées avec celles ci se sont
déroulées ailleurs en france à lille des
centaines de manifestants se sont
retrouvés sur la grand place de nombreux
drapeaux palestiniens
allamand rassemblés à l'appel de
l'association france palestine et de la
communauté palestinienne du nord des
héros ou d'éclater jets de gaz
lacrymogènes des forces de l'ordre là
aussi con tre tirs de projectiles de
certains manifestants
du côté de marseille les protestataires
ont commémoré la nakba l'exode des
arabes en 48 lors de la proclamation de
l'état d'israël je propose d'écouter ces
quelques manifestants
est-ce qu'il est triste c'est que le
monde ne nous bouge pas personne ne
réagit personne ne réagit on est tous au
goût de ce qui se passe mais personne ne
réagit c'est comme si on était en train
d'écraser des mouches et ils vivent le
martyre actuellement notamment le peuple
de gaza
donc je suis venu aujourd'hui pour
apporter ma petite risée un problème le
problème de la palestine sans problème
de colonisation il faut arriver à la
décolonisation mais à ce moment là on
arrivera à régler le problème
on va le dire c'est quelque chose qui
nous a beaucoup touché nous on a
beaucoup vu sur les réseaux c'est ça
maintenant la génération des mines est
assez peu sur les réseaux et toutes les
vidéos qu'on a vu franchement ça nous a
horriblement touchés franchement je
comprends pas comment on peut faire ça
un pays à des familles à des enfants des
personnes âgées raid à des êtres humains
en fait tout simplement est rédacteur en
chef de la revue politique et
parlementaire arnaud benedetti revient
sur la posture de l'exécutif face à ces
manifestations pro palestiniennes on
écoute la préoccupation réformant
première du gouvernement encore cette
affaire perlite et d'apporter le conflit
israélo palestinien en france où l'on
sait qu'il existe un certain nombre de
tensions communautaires et on peut
imaginer que dans finalement la la la la
volonté des ministres à l'intérieur
d'interdire cette manifestation via la
préfecture de police
il y avait vraiment cette préoccupation
ensuite la gestion sur le terrain
suggestion que l'on rencontre maintenant
depuis plusieurs mois à voir maintenant
depuis plusieurs années lors de ce type
de rassemblement avec d'inévitables
échauffourée avec une police qui est
aujourd'hui aussi extrêmement mobilisés
est extrêmement fatiguée parce que il
faut bien comprendre que dans le mamba
d'emmanuel macro nous avons connu des
crises successives où les forces de
l'ordre auraient été très souvent ils
ont mobilisé et un peu partout dans le
monde se sont déroulés des rassemblement
en soutien aux palestiniens en australie
à londres ou encore à paris on vient
d'en parler regarder
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
la grèce est proche et toi et les
fraîches et sera
[Applaudissements]
et la situation au proche orient malgré
les efforts régionaux pour obtenir un
cessez-le-feu les tirs de roquettes du
hamas et les raids aériens de l'armée
israélienne se poursuivent ce samedi une
frappe israélienne a ciblé l'immeuble
d'une dizaine des tâches qui abrite les
locaux de la chaîne de télévision
qatarie al jazeera et l' agence de
presse américaine associated press
garantir la sécurité des médias est
capital réagi cet après midi la maison
blanche à l'attention d'israël
cette nuit ce sont dix membres d'une
même famille qui ont été tués toujours
dans la bande de gaza lors d'un raid
parmi les victimes huit enfants et deux
femmes
l'armée israélienne a indiqué que des
équipements militaires du hamas le
mouvement islamiste au pouvoir dans l
enclave palestinienne se trouvaient dans
la tour frappés par ces avions de combat
côté palestinien des roquettes sont
tirées en direction d'israël la plupart
détruite par le dôme de fer systèmes de
défense aérienne israélien le conflit a
coûté la vie déjà à au moins 139
palestiniens neuf morts côté israélien
les autorités israéliennes ont annoncé
poursuivre leurs opérations
le hamas a commis une grave erreur en
décidant de tirer sur l'état d'israël
l'armée israélienne répond par une
attaque au cours de laquelle nous
opérons sur la base de plans préparés
il y à d'autres étapes prête à être
engagés nous frappons avec une force
significative qui prend de multiples
facettes et c'est un coup dur pour les
capacités de production d'armes du hamas
et du jihad islamique palestinien
cela leur prendra beaucoup de temps pour
se reconstruire c'est dans notre
correspondante palace l'ier qui se
trouve tout près de la frontière entre
territoires palestiniens et israël les
israéliens ont détruit de nombreuses
plateformes de lancement de roquettes ce
qui pourrait conduire deux fait sa une
désescalade ces prochains jours
il sera expirée essayèrent de nettoyer
en juin à l'occasion c'est à dire je
détruire autant de plateformes de
lancement de roquettes
autant il
lieux occupés par le hamas que possible
vendredi cinq ans ce sont des lancements
à gaza ont été détruites et donc
effectivement on commence à parler de
désescalade dans les journées à venir
mais c'est difficile à dire tout ce que
je peux vous dire c'est que la situation
sur le terrain alors ils se retrouvent
un samedi après-midi en général dans la
rue afin de passer une agréable et bien
et tous les magasins sont fermés et il
n'y a personne dans les rues sinon par
la police les tanks et les journalistes
les gens restent chez eux ils ont peur
et des centaines de gazaouis ont fui les
lieux certains se sont abrités dans des
écoles gérées par le programme des
nations unies pour les réfugiés de
palestine beaucoup traumatisés par les
bombardements
nous étions assis lorsque les
bombardements ont commencé la maison
trembler et les enfants hurlaient et le
feu s'est déclaré partout la fenêtre est
tombé sur les enfants et dieu merci ils
ont survécu
les maisons sont touchées par les bombes
il cible les maisons avec des résidents
à l'intérieur et partie de la bande de
gaza le conflit s'étend désormais à la
cisjordanie mais aussi aux villes mixtes
d'israël situation tendue entre juifs et
arabes israéliens avec des affrontements
dans la rue parfois violent regarder des
scènes d'affrontements parfois d'une
extrême violence
sous le regard impuissant des forces de
l'ordre israéliennes depuis plusieurs
jours les villes mixtes en israël sont
le théâtre d'importantes tensions
communautaires et puissante et du
phénomène
la ville de lod situé à quelques
kilomètres de tel aviv
d'un côté des juifs ultranationalistes
de l'autre des arabes israéliens
chacun s'accuse ans d'être à l'origine
des provocations
après les trois dernières soirées nous
ne sortions plus nous savions que nous
ne pouvions pas sortir parce que les
arabes étaient là ils se rassembler en
groupes et commencer à nous jeter des
pierres et à brûler nos affaires
les colons sont venus vers les
habitations et ont cassé des fenêtres
ils ont essayé de rentrer ils ont fait
peur à ma femme et à mes enfants
ils ont brûlé les voitures ici pour
tenter de contenir la violence dans la
ville
et face aux stigmates encore visibles
des heurts de ces derniers jours
comme cette synagogue qui a été incendié
les autorités israéliennes ont annoncé
le déploiement de renforts massifs dans
les villes mixtes du pays l'état
d'urgence a également été décrété à lod
mais signe que la fracture est profonde
il n'ya pas seulement ces affrontements
il y a aussi des agressions ciblées sur
ces images de vidéosurveillance un juif
est attaquée à jérusalem ici il faut lé
d'ultranationalistes lynchage chauffeur
arabe dans une banlieue de tel aviv
la scène a été diffusé en direct à la
télévision
une situation d'anarchie
selon les mots du premier ministre
israélien benyamin nétanyahou qu'il
qualifie même de deuxième front après
celui qui oppose israël au hamas aux
citoyens d'israël jeudi que je me fiche
que votre sang bouillonne vous ne pouvez
pas vous faire justice vous même vous ne
pouvez pas venir et prendre un citoyen
arabe et essayer de le lyncher
tout comme on ne peut pas avoir des
citoyens arabes faire cela des citoyens
juifs à lod
un peu plus d'un tiers des habitants de
cette ville moyenne et arabes cela fait
des décennies qu'il cohabite de manière
relativement
visible avec leurs concitoyens juifs au
gré des conflits mais depuis plusieurs
années cette ville pauvre a vu arriver
de plus en plus de sionistes religieux
alors la menace d'expulsion de
palestiniens à jérusalem est ravivé la
crainte qui existent aussi dans cette
ville du centre d'israël
résultats des groupes souvent jeunes se
radicaliser s'affrontent
la situation inquiète les autorités
politiques et religieuses et malgré les
appels au calme répéter les discours
belliqueux du hamas et de netanyahu ont
des répercussions très directe dans les
rues des villes mixtes israélienne 1
questionner la réaction de la communauté
internationale face à ces événements qui
oppose israéliens et palestiniens on a
appris en fin de journée que le
président américain joe biden s'était
entretenu à la fois avec le premier
ministre israélien benyamin netanyahu et
le chef de l'autorité palestinienne
mahmoud abbas
l'éclairage de gérard vespière
fondateurs du web magazine le monde
décrypté la situation est quand même
difficile parce qu'elle a se compose de
trois volets un volet de société il y à
1 heure sociétal entre la composante
israélienne et la composante arabe dans
l'ensemble de la région
donc il y à un militaire on voit des
frappes très très nombreuses et puis
aussi un volet politique avec la
situation donc de netanyahu qui est un
premier ministre sortant qui peut être
premier ministre appelant ou rappelé
donc ce qui peut intervenir entre
washington et l'ensemble des parties et
bien c'est un appel au calme en appelle
à la raison à washington a repris depuis
quelques semaines le financement à
l'aide financière au prêt donc des
autorités palestiniennes
donc il y a une capacité de dialogue de
la part des états unis qu'il n'y avait
pas il ya quelques mois lors de la
précédente présidence américaine
donc là il ya une une ouverture
effectivement possible au dialogue et l
écoute
et dans le reste de l'actualité c'était
il ya dix ans que le mouvement des
indignés investissez les places
espagnoles pour protester contre la
crise le chômage ou encore la corruption
portant une critique radicale du système
économique le mouvement lance alors de
nouvelles réformes de contestation et
qui essaime au delà des frontières
espagnoles et porte encore leurs fruits
aujourd'hui
détails en images
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous
[Musique]
où
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et on revient sur ce mouvement des
indignés avec josé rojas c'est alonso
juriste et ancien secrétaire général du
parti socialiste ouvrier espagnol de
paris bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous
assure rt france rappelait new skies a
lancé il y a dix ans le mouvement des
indignés
bonsoir merci pour votre invitation
basse qui a démarré on va dire le
mouvement des indignados en espagne
c'est une sorte de ras-le-bol général et
surtout c'est une situation de crise
économique et sociale profonde en 2011
après le début de cette crise économique
non seulement espagnol mais mondiale en
2008 2009 ce qui a provoqué que beaucoup
de jeunes qui étaient déjà
structurellement dans une situation de
précarité affronte la situation
économique et sociale et le marché du
travail avec encore plus de difficultés
la phr la crise économique avait frappé
très durement l'espagne avec une montée
très rapide du chômage de grosses
difficultés des réformes inévitable à
faire y compris sous le gouvernement
socialiste de zapatero et beaucoup de
revendications des jeunes qui voyait se
fermer de plus en plus leur avenir en
plus tard qu'est ce qu'il reste de cette
contestation portée par les indignés
alors c'est intéressant parce que
il ya eu la création du fameux partis
politiques podemos avec son leader
pablo iglesias mais qui a fait en
quelque sorte un peu long feu c'est à
dire ils se sont absolument présenter
comme les héritiers de ce mouvement
spontané ce mouvement de rue ce
mouvement essentiellement composé de
jeunes et c'est un parti qui a été créée
les dires de toutes pièces par pop
boulot iglesias et ses amis
universitaires qui a eu un succès un
premier succès aux élections européennes
de 2014 en se revendiquant de ce
mouvement des indignés et en annonçant
que c'était le parti politique qui
allait faire la transition entre le
mouvement de rue et les réformes
sociales
le problème c'est que beaucoup des
revendications qui avait été présenté
par le mouvement spontané des indignados
beaucoup de ces revendications
aujourd'hui n'est pas du tout satisfait
notamment la question des frais de
scolarité des frais universitaires qui
pour les jeunes et sont très importants
en espagne beaucoup plus qu'en france ou
dans la plupart des pays européens
sondés feraient extrêmement élevé et par
exemple ces deux revendications là n'a
pas été satisfaites
aux dernières élections régionales à
madrid le seul candidat qui proposait
une réduction voire une gratuité de
certains frais universitaires c'était le
candidat socialiste gabilondo et pas du
tout par exemple le parti podemos qui
est resté sur des revendications
sociales parfois un peu maximaliste
c'est à dire on veut avoir tour et tout
de suite si dans la nature de ce genre
de mouvements qui sont les mouvements
plutôt radicaux de revendications et
total et on s'aperçoit que ba
aujourd'hui qu'est ce qu'il reste de ce
mouvement là la traduction politique
qu'a voulu faire podemos de ce mouvement
de contestation de protestation dans les
institutions
ce rôle de représentation en fait a vite
tourné court parce que aujourd'hui
beaucoup de ces indignados où beaucoup
même des militants du parti podemos
contestent la politique du parti podemos
il ya eu énormément de divisions au sein
même du mouvement podemos qui est devenu
finalement un mouvement minoritaire qui
a cru un moment dépassé le parti
socialiste espagnol mais qui est retombé
à un niveau plus conforme j'allais dire
à la réalité de sa capacité de
représentation c'est d'ailleurs autour
de 10 11% des électeurs espagnols ce qui
est beaucoup moins impressionnant que
les 20 30% que parfois ici est de
revendiquer les responsables de polemos
et notamment son leader pablo iglesias
alors comment est ce que vous expliquer
cet essoufflement d'information
politique podemos est ce que cela
correspond à une forme de contestation
espagnole qui est retombé ces dernières
années non je pense pas que ce soit une
somme je pense que c'est une forme de
désillusion
c'est une forme de désillusion le site
très difficile de toute façon de deux de
traduire un mouvement de rue dans un
mouvement politique durable sur le long
terme les mouvement des indignados
qu'est-ce qu'il refait ce qu'ils
demandent et finalement ils demandaient
en réalité tout simplement la
satisfaction de revendications qui sont
des satisfaction des revendications de
jeunes sur beaucoup de questions et
quand on veut faire tout en même temps
où et quand l'un podemos promettait tout
en même temps promettez de bouleverser
la vie politique promettez des réformes
sociales économiques et même politiques
même institutionnels dans tous les sens
c'est l'un des partis qui réclament avec
beaucoup d'insistance un référendum sur
le maintien ou pas de la monarchie
constitutionnelle en espagne c'est un
parti qui ouvertement républicain c'est
pas le seul mais c'est un parti qui par
exemple sur cette question-là a voulu en
faire une question prioritaire ce qui
est pas la question institutionnelle à
mon avis la plus urgente c'est une
question qui mérite débat mais qui n'est
pas la plus urgente est lorsque le parti
podemos commence à être représentés dans
les institutions
d'abord dans les mairies ne faut pas
oublier que c'est un parti qui a eu
beaucoup de succès dans les élections
européennes de 2014 et qui ensuite a
investi beaucoup de conseils municipaux
en espagne des gouvernements régionaux
également mais qui finalement a échoué
en fait à traduire dans des mesures
rapides et concrètes
cette revendication ses revendications
générales que afficher le parti
politique podemos dans ses campagnes
électorales donc il ya une sorte de il
ya une sorte de d'écart entre les
promesses et les réalisations concrètes
une fois qu'on arrive aux institutions
le deuxième le deuxième spécificité on
va dire de du rôle de podemos dans les
institutions c'est que na ne dépend ça
ne dépasseront pas la majorité absolue
et de loin de là on est obligé de faire
des pactes c'est comme ça donc dans les
institutions dans les gouvernements
régionaux locaux il faut il faut
conclure des pactes notamment avec la
gauche et peut demos a eu énormément
mal à accepter cette culture du pacte
qui pourtant existe en espagne qui qui
qui s'est pratiqué très longtemps avec
notamment le parti socialiste espagnol
mais c'est podemos avec son côté un peu
maximaliste radical a longtemps refusé
de jouer le règle du dd les règles du
jeu démocratique qui consiste à créer
des gouvernements de coalition et a cédé
un peu lorsqu'on n'est pas majoritaire
il faut savoir aussi cédé pour obtenir
quelque chose et ça c'est quelque chose
que les dirigeants de peau des mots sont
ils ont beaucoup de mal à accepter
l'acceptent désormais dans le
gouvernement de gauche de pedro sanchez
au niveau de l'état espagnol
mais parfois ça a été très difficile ça
a été très compliqué d'ailleurs
d'arriver à ce gouvernement de coalition
au niveau de l'espagne d'un montrait
très rapidement parce que le temps nous
manque malheureusement est ce que vous
direz que bien que demos pèse beaucoup
moins lourd aujourd'hui dans le champ
politique espagnole est ce que vous
direz que il a toutefois été il a
toutefois inspiré les courants
politiques espagnols plus
traditionnelles établies contraint
finalement de de prendre note de cette
de ce mouvement populaire est ce que
plus largement c'est ce mouvement
espagnol qui a inspiré des mouvements
comme les geôles en france d'un mot s'il
vous plaît je ne suis pas sûr qu'il est
il le seul la seule source d'inspiration
au niveau de l'espagne bien sûr
l'apparition de podemos et d'un autre
parti aussi qui décide à dano ce qui est
en train de disparaître maintenant a
forcément bousculer les partis
politiques traditionnels
il a surtout remis en cause le
bipartisme traditionnelle qu'on voyait
au niveau de toutes les institutions
espagnoles
il a remis en cause mon nom mon avis c
est ce que véritablement ça a été
faire un bilan globalement positive je
ne suis pas sûr parce qu'il y à beaucoup
a critiqué aussi dans l'attitude de
certains dirigeants de poney moss est
cette attitude un peu parfois extrêmes
et radicales qui facilite pas justement
les accords les grands accords entre
différents partis parfois il faut
accepter de mettre un peu d'eau dans son
vin de céder sur certaines choses pour
obtenir des résultats concrets et fait
je crois que la tradition politique de
podemos est encore trop récente pour
peut-être comprendre cette nécessité qui
est la réalité politique dans non
seulement en espagne mais dans tous les
pays
merci beaucoup d'avoir répondu à notre
invitation sur arte france josé rojas
alonso juriste on sert secrétaire
général du parti socialiste ouvrier
espagnol de paris merci à vous d'avoir
suivi c'est la fin de cette édition se
retrouve dans une trentaine de minutes à
tout à l'heure
[Musique]
et y'a pas une façon plus une pauvre de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collective
vous savez pour moi que dès qu'on dit il
n'y a pas d'alternative on sort du
politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre